[Music]
san francisco california is where we go
now kristin is there kristin how can we
help
hi ken hi um george how are you guys
doing today we are having a blast what's
going on with you
okay so um my call kind of has to do
with the last guy who called
but in a different sense so my husband
and i got married and we moved into a
house and the roommate that was living
with him before we got married came with
us to the new house which was fine
because it's helped with the bills so we
don't have to cover everything
but now he's basically moved into his
girlfriend
she's stayed every night for the last
four months
she showers here she washes clothes here
she eats here
but we talked to him about it said she
needs to start paying rent if she's
going to stay here that much because we
do pay
quite a bit more than him for the bills
here
and he said she's a guest she doesn't
need to pay bills she has to pay bills
um
elsewhere
and we're not really sure what to do if
we should try terminating our lease
early but i know that costs money or if
we should try removing his name off of
the lease if you even know if that's
possible
oh boy sticky situation here
so what is the lease agreement what does
it say and who who owns that
um so the lease agreement is my husband
me and the roommate all three of our
names are on it and it's
for a year so we started in june until
next year next june and then
per the
regulations it says that there should no
there should not be any subletting and
nobody else besides the people who are
on the lease agreement should be living
here
um that's pretty clear to me and yeah
there's your there's your there's your
technical out have you told him that
that hey this is in the lease agreement
um no we haven't told him that
yet
um who's the enforcer who's the who's
the actual enforcer in that contract
the enforcer would be our landlord who
lives we live
about like an hour east of san francisco
but my landlord lives in l.a
so well i'd be on the phone really here
to like check yeah well
i mean your technical out is that clause
and the landlord to be your heavy but
this is still going to be a tough
conversation and at some point we got to
be big boys and big girls
and
he either does it your way or
you get the landlord involved
okay
yeah
and i hope you've learned a lesson here
i hate to sound like dad oh yeah but
goodness gracious my husband and i are
both like
wow we
are never going to do this again
so you guys are all renting as part of
this lease so it's not like you're
you're not gaining anything financially
other than you have a roommate to split
with correct
yeah so like the
all total we pay like 3 000 for bills
for just to live in the house and he
pays about 900 how did you so we feel
like we're housing a child now well part
of me goes it's not like you own the
house is there another situation
obviously i want him out and to get a
better roommate if he's not going to
agree to these terms i don't like the
idea of the girlfriend moving into the
situation either does that cramp the
space a little bit to have four people
in there
um no it's a big enough house for it but
we just feel like he is disrespecting
the agreement that we agreed upon
and
this girl isn't paying anything and
she's staying here for free which you're
not allowed to stay anywhere for free
she's going to explain that she's got
the great
the greatest gig right now yeah
rent-free and yeah san francisco
yeah were you guys good friends with
this clown before this or is this just a
sheer my husband
yeah my husband is close friend so
that's where it gets sticky no it
doesn't no it doesn't say thank you very
much chris can i just tell you you need
to tell your husband what i'm saying
your husband needs to man up
my goodness gracious if one of my
friends was doing this to me it'd be a
one-on-one bro conversation come on man
this is it you i your husband should be
ashamed of himself you shouldn't even
have to be dealing with this he needs to
man up and tell this dude
figure it out you play by the rules or
you're out dude but this guy is taking
advantage of your husband he is he has
taken advantage of his kindness or shall
i say taking advantage of his
lack of confrontation skills or a
stomach for confrontation
am i about right
um he's a police officer so he knows how
to have confrontation i think it's the
kindness part that
well he needs to take off the kindness
hat and he needs to put on the
confrontation hat and pull out the old
night stick too
you know
i'd be tapping it on my thigh hey man
listen up here you know look this this
is unfortunately ken's saying this he's
being good cop right now we've got to
see a little bit of that bad cop if you
want to see the situation uh be resolved
i don't like if i'm in your shoes i'm
going this guy's out and if i've got to
use the landlord to fix it if i've got
to get the husband to to have this
conversation since it's his friend and
like you said if it's a friend it's a
different level of conversation
it's not a stranger you met on
craigslist is going hey dude if she
stays here she pays rent that's the rule
george you know me i'm old school man
you are i'm old school i i mean this
might just be grabbing the guy by the
back of the collar and the back of the
pants
ken come on i'm not saying actual
violence i'm saying it's one of those
come on like he just needs to lower the
boom on this guy and go dude you're a
child you're acting like a child but now
let's focus on the back side of this the
lesson here first of all i don't like
the deal that he was paying 900. yeah
they were paying now sometimes they go
well if you've got the master bedroom
with the in-suite bathroom you pay a
little more that's that's
i don't like it so i don't know their
situation there but if i'm in their
shoes maybe it could be better to have a
stranger who just keeps to themselves
who's clean and you get a different
roommate who you don't have to deal with
did you have any language in your
wedding vows that said leave and cleave
you ever remember that part i remember
that part leaving cleve
if you can't afford an apartment without
a roommate after if you're a married
couple then you you need to slow down
you need to do something less i don't
like the idea of any new married couple
quite frank you know i just don't like
it yeah and then
they're in the san francisco area so
they may know if they went they're
paying three grand three people maybe
they could find a spot for two grand
that's smaller and still work for them
if they want to be on their own but
living in that area high cost of living
it gets tough because you're gonna pay
three four grand on your own but
hopefully the income is there to support
that too if you're legitimate it just i
just there needs to be boundaries for a
new married couple and married couples
in general and having a i mean it'd be
one thing if it's a room over the garage
but sharing one house i don't know dude
yeah but i mean you're younger you're
making all kinds of excuses well we've
we've read the article the millennials
are buying houses together
co-buying with friends oh nightmare
waiting to happen